If possible, to customize ChatGPT,
to give it more information about yourself
and to make sure that the responses
are a bit more tailored to you.
In order to do this,
we're gonna leverage something called custom instructions.
If you go into the top right of your page,
click on your profile icon.
After that, I want you to go
and click on Customize ChatGPT.
You can then go and click on the bottom left,
click on Enable for New Chats,
and then I can do things such as tell ChatGPT my name,
what I do,
and you can also give it some specific traits.
So how do you want ChatGPT to respond?
And is there anything else
that you want ChatGPT to know about you?
You can go to the Advanced section
and you can also change or toggle
what type of capabilities
you want ChatGPT to have access to.
So for example, web search,
Dalet, which would produce images,
code, i.e. can run and execute code,
canvas, and then you've also got advanced voice.
So what I want you to do is spend a couple of minutes
and it's thinking about what kind of traits
do you want to have ChatGPT using?
And also, is there anything else that you want to add in here
so that ChatGPT has more information about you?
Doing that, you can just click Save,
and then that'll basically customize your ChatGPT
for all of your future messages.
In the next video, we're gonna look at
how you can utilize ChatGPT memory
so that ChatGPT can understand information
across lots of your different chat histories.